[Musique]
bientôt vers di lauro signolet nid
d'amour à eminem est en train de voler
la wii il faudra vous en gardez quelques
sud pour casser la croûte de ses
compagnons perdre l'acquis et la
compagnie perlières c'est un bien grand
mot
elle se limite en fait à une dizaine
d'oiseaux car là comme ailleurs le
gibier se fait rare mais tradition
oblige en dordogne en chasse sauvage et
comme nous sommes en périgord c'est
évidemment sous un noyer avec un
casse-croûte digne de ce nom que nous
nous reposerons en parlant chasse bien
sûr et alors qu'elles soient en fait tu
voulais manger tous ensemble après on va
dîner ensemble en images et puis c'est
fini on ne pourra plus emballé sur une
partie de plaisir c'est une cellule
nous regardons ça comme du sport mais
croyez moi la chasse c'est un équilibre
nature il faut que quelques-uns il faut
en laisser il faut un panier c'est comme
ça qu'il faut faire nous le regardons en
voyant ces dames à tout commentaire
super drôle
faire comme ma grand mère qui était
malade ligne je vais vous en faire une
partie à l'accord la tortière à la
cocotte avec le chou et puis l'autre
d'harry à la portière entreprises pour
réussir cette recette il faut tout
d'abord évident et bardé poivrer et
saler les perdreaux on liquide auraient
ensuite les deux côtés madame ans plus
tard on prépare d'autre part une pâte
brisée
on pose les deux tiers de celles ci au
fond d'un moule à balader en périgord
patrie du foie gras il est évidemment
moins onéreux de poser au fond de la
tourtière du foie gras frais mais c'est
facultatif
on place ensuite sur celui de foie gras
les perdreaux couper en quartiers
on confectionne un couvercle avec le
reste de la pâte en ménageant quelques
cheminées et on passe à four chaud
pendant 30 minutes environ
alfred hitchcock quand même le seul
pernod qu'elle la revendait ce matin je
croyais que j'avais pris des plombes ati
c'est bizarre d'être et c'est juste que
les sais pas ce que je fais un voeu soit
[Musique]
la journée n'a pas été si mauvaise que
cela c'est sûr
une façon de se retrouver entre amis à
l'ombre d'un noyé à l'affût derrière un
bosquet ou autour d'une table un moment
de vie bien vécu en somme
[Musique]